when you decide that you really want to
invoke permanent change you start
playing to win all the time if you tell
me you're gonna do something young lady
if you don't do it I'll rip your head
off and [ __ ] down your neck if you don't
love yourself you can't be a good
husband a good father a good anything
love you first need motivation what to
top 10 with believe nation
he's dan Pena and here's my take on his
top ten rules a success vol 5 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one always play to win am a number of
you who started a business at one time
in a lot in your life
the first 50,000 100,000 euros in
revenue when you start is geometric
growth so everybody that has ever
started a business generated any income
that's a geometric growth because it
started with ground 0 to the first 50
100 everybody with me okay what happens
you stop playing to win and you start
playing not to lose if when not if but
when you decide that you really want to
invoke permanent change you start
playing to win all the time and nobody
preaches that they say keep six months
reserved in your bank account right in
case you lose your job that's that's a
common [ __ ] for the first 30 years
of my life I spent 125 percent of every
penny that I made every year I was
always as you would say in depth instead
of debt I don't know why I called a
debit any in depth why because I didn't
want any backup I didn't want any Plan B
I either succeeded or died financially
rule number two have high standards qlae
works for not just money this kid came
to me two years ago he had never
finished higher than 20th and university
archery he was on the archery team and
Britain never finished higher than 20th
and any meet he'd ever attended
this is him finishing first in Great
Britain a year and a half later first
the little skinny wimp [ __ ]
he couldn't even pull the thing back I
didn't realize you know they've got 60
pound bows so he goes and get 140 pound
bow well he doesn't weigh 140 pounds
finish first
he was firing 50 to 100 arrows I said
you fire 500 arrows a day for the next
year and you'll win his little arms
would quiver couldn't get the thing back
blisters cut through his hands he's the
champ now your goal has got to be high
standards I talked to a couple of kids
in financial planning kids here and I
happen to know a lot about financial
planning being one of the forerunners 50
years ago and most of the kids that go
into that wealth management as it's
called now don't set the standard high
enough you don't want to manage money
for people that have two or five or ten
million you want a man money for people
that have a hundred five hundred in a
billion but they don't teach you that
during the training programs at Merrill
Lynch goldman sachs etcetera cetera
because they realized that only one in a
hundred is going to attain that goal and
they want a hundred of you with five
million in your book not one of you with
a billion in your book rule number three
focus on the few not the many focus on a
few not many and I've been given that
advice for 25 years and I was given that
advice when I was with the Onassis
people and we think we think about too
many different things and we try to do
too many things virtually everybody
almost everybody in the group is trying
to do too many things and the and the
most successful not unlike you Josh you
focused
once you pivoted on one thing until you
got the ball across the goal line until
you got the deal financed and until you
get the actual money financed and the
exchange contracts as it's called in
this country the deal is not over until
the fat lady sings until it's over and I
see you gave it an example being on the
1-inch line two or three times and I see
a lot of kids falter at the one-inch
line the either because they're working
on something else or they allow
something else to obstruct their
ultimate goal rule number four work hard
Jack Welch arguably the greatest CEO in
the history of the world who managed in
General Electric for 20-25 years
he said there was no work/life balance
there worth work life challenges and we
make decisions and we live with him do
you think Elon Musk has worked life
balance no do you think Steve Jobs when
he was alive had work-life balance no do
you think Bill Gates no Henry Ford no
original Heineken no so none of those
people that created the wealth of the
world had work-life balance why do you
think you're gonna have it why cuz you
deserve it I don't think so you deserve
what you get in life by working hard
also if you want to learn how to have
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below but no one does
know initially upfront you have to try
if the swing at the plate a kid like you
if you had to keep track of seven days a
week 24 hours a day what you do rule
number five be tough I drove by a
college today and yelled boo 35 people
went to the hospital 734 needed crisis
counseling 429 needed a safe area or
room and classes were cancelled for a
week there are universities that I've
spoken at that have safe floors the
third floor in the physics building in
Cracow University has a safe floor if
life gets too tougher than they go to
that floor to chill the Air Force
Academy has safeguards when they're yeah
we have a Naval Academy guys so he said
that they pull when they're being beat
up too much enlisted man going through
boot camp have safe cards that they pull
or lucky we don't go to war with Russia
they'll eat our lunch they're gonna eat
us alive we're lucky there are no safe
cards
in life I tell the kids all the time if
we're at war we'd all be dead see you're
used to making mistakes and nothing
happens for the few of you in the
military in here you know mistakes and
cost lives my our kids are Millennials
but they're not I mean you'd think that
they were Godzilla a tiller of the Hun
and Genghis Khan compared to them other
Millennials our daughter is me with a
skirt she's a rough she's a rough girl
daddy why do you want to go if you were
standing here she said my daddy treats
everybody the same like whether you're
the Pope although I do cut the pump some
slack that's not quite accurate whether
you're you know whoever I mean I treat
everybody the same because I hold
everybody accountable if you tell me
you're gonna do something young lady if
you don't do it I'll rip your head off
down your neck I'll be all over you like
like like a cheap suit rule number six
be willing to make sacrifices at
seven-and-a-half billion people on the
planet and my my guesstimate is world
there's only about seven or eight
hundred thousand of us on the planet
that are willing to make the sacrifices
of these we focus commitment and it's
just like a premier athletes you know
there's a lot of people to run 100
two-hour - but there's very few of them
that make it the Olympics and there's
even a fewer that matter rule number
seven love yourself first I love myself
nobody my wife got god bless you would
say I
I worship the ground don't get mad at me
Sally I worship the ground an walks on
but my love for him is transitory for
the love he has for himself self-esteem
if you don't love yourself you can't be
a good husband a good father or good
anything love you first and I have no
problem and I've been that way even when
I was doing bad things
rule number eight have a dream now this
is me my best attempt to be a cholo in
East LA
that was taken 25 years ago in front of
where my house used to be and if you can
tell my house is from the chain-link
fence to the brick wall wasn't very big
house was it 800 square feet when we
were taking that picture in 1993 there
was two drive-by shootings within the
neighborhood and my camera guys jumped
under the car
that's why I come from this is where I
lived in 1972 on Wall Street 14 years
later I think it was 12 years later I
lived there I lived in little they used
to call him when they had no I forget
what they call but anyway a little
apartment I had III lived in a place
called the bedbug bedford but we call it
the beg bug because castro cockroaches
were that big
qualen we used to sit there and watch
our little TV and we'd see the
cockroaches racing back and forth the
floor six of us in a two-bedroom
apartment
and then twelve years not dissimilar to
President Obama I had a dream that I was
going to be living a castle on an island
and twelve years later I moved in rule
number nine dress well-dressed like the
president of the prime minister of your
country you only have one time to make
the first impression kids you come in
looking like some of you I wouldn't give
you toilet paper most of you I be
embarrassed the way you're dressed and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is just do you
the fifty billion dollar man that guy
yes yes he doesn't give a [ __ ] though
yeah that's what least almost dead I
don't think we could play a stuff
without getting suit Jamie hello Joe my
name is Dan pena I'm still up for a more
durable force at six one to twenty five
and if you think that I'm almost dead
and I'm not gonna be alive anymore
ask this bear that I killed with a knife
not too long ago I'm still a very tough
guy
at 71 I take no Bush in person or on the
YouTube I'm not dead and I'm plenty
alive and I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody says about me I rip people's
head off and down their neck and from
one tough guy to another tough guy don't
be afraid don't be scared to use my
stuff on your podcast it's all free you
ask me why do you give it away free Dan
I give it away free to take the last
excuse away from the sorry why they
can't fulfill their dreams I'm calling
you out Joe you think you're a tough guy
you haven't met me on the fifty billion
dollar man and this is my lair
[Music]
now I've got a special bonus tip from
Dan on how you can be all you can be
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go
question number one where do you need to
raise your standards number two where do
you need to toughen up and number three
where should you focus on the few not
the many I believe you're put on the
earth to be all we can be not a fraction
thereof oh there's nobody in this room
that puts their hand on their heart and
says all my life I've been all that I
can be this is all I can be if that's
the case then you ought to blow your
brains out metaphorically speaking Steve
Jobs only wore black remember Zuckerberg
now it's kind of copying that but I
Sally picks all my clothes she dresses
me this suit is a fifty billion dollar
man suit the pinstripes 850 billion
dollar man I mean the I don't do
anything except think about how to make
you retards better you know why I have a
sore back 25 years of caring you
badasses across the goal-line 25 years
and not everybody deserves to be alive
so let's get that thing straight right
now and if you think that you're a
[ __ ]
some of you should have rolled down the
inside of your top mama's legs and
that's the God's truth
if you want 10 more rules from then pina
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
it's never gonna get any better than
this kids this is the eyes I said on
YouTube the eye of the perfect storm
so I'm saying no matter what your age is